for me to finally be accused of being
with a man it would be someone that
looked like Mark Braddock it's actually
in the transcript that he had only been
with his wife and me and he it was just
something he wanted to try nah I ain't
that small spoon that you get at Baskin
and Robbins Todd Chrisley slamming the
claim he's gay and had an affair I mean
a toad I mean some that looks like a
thumb there's nothing else for you to
know about us it's all out there so
there's no Bombshells while hosting
christly confessions with his son Chase
Todd who's weeks away from serving his
prison sentence sets the record straight
about his sexual orientation for me to
finally be accused of being with a man
it would be someone that looked like
Mark Braddock yeah exactly I mean a toad
I mean some that looks like a thumb yeah
Todd definitely not a fan of his former
business associate Mark Braddock who
testified about their alleged fling
during his and wife Julie's fraud trial
in November somebody who says he's only
had sex with his wife and me let me tell
you something I can understand if you'd
have had sex with me hat with Randy
crazy I get that there have been many
that have been advertised by your daddy
but now that little short sawed-off
thing was was wishful thinking Todd
can't help a cracker joke or two he even
jokes that he wishes the claims were
made by Hollywood a-listers instead if
George Clooney had gone out here Brad
Pitt down here said you know
down with Todd Chrisley
I ain't gonna be I'm not gonna be now
they're gonna run with that I don't care
let him run with it I'm not gonna be as
embarrassed by it but to say that it was
somebody that looked like him I would
love to say it's all scripted but you
can't script the dysfunction that goes
on
Todd and Julie report to their
respective Florida prisons on January
17th where they'll be serving a combined
19-year sentence but I think it's
natural that you feel sorry for yourself
because you're grieving you're grieving
it's a grieving process I had to say to
Savannah I said you need to find Grace
and that's exactly what Todd and Julie's
25 year old daughter is doing that at
the end of the day the truth always
comes out and to just kind of be patient
with myself E.T caught up with Savannah
just days ahead of her parents
sentencing she said they're cooping by
turning to their faith they're pushing
through
um we have just we're at a place where
we put our faith in God we definitely
don't put our faith and the system I've
never seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith and in prayer
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith
foreign